hey there guys
right my name is lament don't call me
doctor I'm not a doctor I work for a
doctor sometimes anyhow they asked me to
come talk to you guys for a little bit
today normally someone else does this so
just bear with me I guess right right
so listen I'm gonna do my level best to
get this across to you in the nicest way
that I can a lot of you are gonna die
and it's gonna be your own fault I'm
sorry but that's just how it is and
there's a really good reason for it
- I hear in the lunchroom every day
you've seen 6a - man that thing will
annihilate you gold
I saw one seven three snap that guy's
nectar in the last security bridge
scariest thing I ever seen
you care about a 3/5 [ __ ] man to disturb
it you care about the SCP G God you will
that'll happen
because it's what always happens you get
an odd possessive quality something you
can easily describe when you guard nine
one four it's it's yours
damn it just pride you love your CP just
don't you know love your SCP a little
laughs little joke there but uh that's a
good thing you'll get into arguments
about what will be the worst one to
break free or who would win in a fight
you care about what you got you care
about what it can do some level you'll
start to love them and that's how we
know how precious all this [ __ ] even
that [ __ ] mirror who talks to you how
precious it is and really that's where
you [ __ ] see the problem is we don't
really give a damn about what an object
can do essentially at the root of it all
we don't we'd like to know though hell
we have to know but that's not important
containing it is what's important doing
what we have to do to keep people safe
it's why the containment comes first in
all the files it's the most important
thing you guys can still remember your
parents right then we're keeping safe
your grandparents your old friends we
contain these things to protect them see
this is where we always [ __ ] it up the
second they make you forget about
everyone it's not important just
remember right now remember this feeling
hold on to it because eventually you're
gonna slip eventually some of those
carefully craft the procedures something
that dozens of people died so we can
make sure it worked
you're gonna [ __ ] up people will die
maybe even you don't let that happen if
you can remember the feeling of your
parents the emotions that are tied to
all those people on there you can forget
memories but it's hard to forget the
emotions tied to it you hear of little
Albert same thing anyhow so are we to be
such a downer doctor uh writes is that
it doctor writes is gonna make sure
you're all good and healthy give you
some drinks don't bite the pill to
swallow and remember all right
especially for the next little bit try I
uh yeah sorry doctor it's uh it's your
show now I'll see you guys around the
water cooler right
[Music]
you